today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video I told
you just two days ago that coronavirus
is continuing to ravage in particular
some parts of the country but meanwhile
confusingly the country is opening more
and more particularly the parts of the
country that are having the case and
death problems we have a planned Tulsa
Oklahoma
Trump rally with thousands of people on
Saturday dr. Anthony foul he has already
recommended against going to such a
rally rally goers in fact have to sign a
waiver for coronavirus contagion if they
want tickets to this Donald Trump rally
but we now have several more days of
data and the corona virus pandemic in
some particular states is spiking so
quickly so quickly and so aggressively
that the numbers almost seem fake but
they are not fake and what I mean is
when you look at these case graphs that
I'm going to show you we are more than
three months into this pandemic it's
hard to believe that some states are
managing the pandemic so poorly that we
are now getting these spikes like these
states are nowhere near the peaks that
some states reached in early to mid
April looking at Texas for example I
already told you days ago that cases
were spiking in Texas that was nothing
compared to what we are now seeing a
record four thousand cases in one day in
Texas yesterday
these are unconscionable numbers
sticking with this part of the country
Arizona is quickly becoming the hot spot
in terms of case growth rate in the
United States also with a record 2400
cases yesterday when you look at these
charts they're downright dystopian spoke
to a friend in Arizona again everybody's
just acting like nothing's going on he
says stores are open people pack
together
nobody's wearing masks just like almost
no mitigation going on at all Florida
very similar curve have a
a lot of friends in Florida very worried
and again yesterday the worst day in
Florida since all of this started also
thousands of new cases so I really need
people to understand the context here
we're months into this White House
coronavirus task force in place for
months
mitigation testing PPE stay at home
orders wear masks endure months and
months and months and yesterday was the
worst day since the start of this in
Texas Florida and Arizona now it's not
just red states as I've mentioned
California which was an early hotspot
it's still having having problems
they've not exactly flattened the curve
but even the growth rates in California
are not the erratic numbers that we are
seeing in some other places now
meanwhile I continue to be really glad
that things are going well in some
places I'm not saying this to brag it's
just luck that I mean I guess it's not
luck I live in Massachusetts obviously
partially I live here because my family
moved here partially I live in
Massachusetts because I prefer the
politics of Massachusetts to those of
some of these other states the case
curve here just falling off a cliff if
you're watching Connecticut doing really
well lots of states are doing very well
and will see as they start to open
whether that changes so the point here
is mitigation works the cases and the
deaths respond to what people are
actually doing the weather does not seem
to be stopping the spread in warmer
states and as the summer comes and the
Trump administration is just pretending
that it's over things are actually so
bad right now in some states that this
conversation about wave two is
essentially irrelevant in the sense that
there's not going to be a dip it it
seems as though you know we had this
idea wave one would be dying off by late
April early May we might have almost no
new cases by June 1st there were models
that said by June 1 there will be almost
no new cases we've got 20,000 new cases
a day in some of these states there
won't be a wave to because wave one will
never end
wave two was supposed to start you know
maybe September mid September we are now
looking at at least in some states that
have not even hit their peaks just a
continued sustained pandemic through the
end of the year if nothing changes the
way Texas is looking Florida Arizona
it's very difficult to imagine with
cases spiking to where they are now that
there actually will be a dip that we
could call a pause between waves we
could just have a six or eight or nine
month wave until hopefully there is an
effective treatment and a vaccine and
half the country seems to be pretending
that everything is fine
now in terms of you know what's safe in
different places I posted a picture of
myself in Massachusetts over the weekend
sitting outdoors at a cafe it felt safe
given the the numbers here we're down to
only you know one hundred we had only
fifty eight new cases a couple days ago
about a hundred and fifty a day under
two hundred people now left in the ICU
in the entire state I ordered online
I grabbed my coffee and bagel didn't you
know interact with anybody sat outside
at a table nobody around me when I leave
I flip a piece of paper on the table
that goes from green to red so other
people know not to sit there waitstaff
come over and and clean it it seems safe
I mean the the the outdoor contagion is
primarily when people are doing
obviously stupid things crowding
together at you know on a hiking trail
or something like that it seems like
that is relatively safe what we're
seeing in other states where it's
indoors no masks people on top of each
other of course that's going to lead to
spread so you know we talk about the
8020 rule we talk about 80 80 percent of
people are incompetent at whatever
they're doing most of the rules about
even outdoors you should look at wearing
a mask we only need to be doing that
because of the small portion of people
that are just doing stupid things unless
you tell them wear a mask outdoors and
that is something that we can't ignore
when we look at state leadership on down
that's a big part of why some of these
states are having such major problems I
have some absolutely stunning an
incredibly disturbing video to play for
you today
we've
seen examples of just about everything
from the protests of the last couple of
weeks but today it actually pains me to
bring you this video of police in Bethel
Ohio almost being more part of the mob
than the peacekeepers so I'm going to be
playing some video for you of a young
man who was protesting on behalf of the
anti police brutality movement whether
we say this was a black lives matter
protester or not doesn't really matter
this was a young white male that you're
going to see and in the video this man
is at one point surrounded by right-wing
counter protest protesters I guess we
would call them who seemed very unhappy
with him and at a certain point you also
see two police officers drift in and
they're standing right around this guy
including one one police officer right
in front of the camera a middle-aged
white man with an American flag bandana
comes up behind this protester winds up
and punches the guy in the back of the
head right in front of police officers
the police watch and do nothing to the
perpetrators perpetrator who violently
attacked this man when the young man who
was assaulted by police by the counter
protester says to the officer
I was just assaulted what are you going
to do the officer does nothing let's
look at the video
apologies for those just listening today
I've done my best to describe what we
are going to hear and see the audio
doesn't tell the whole story so I
encourage you to find the clip online
for our video audience let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this has to be dealt with they said I
don't know the identity of the two
officers in question here I don't know
the identity of the perpetrator but
certainly with this video spreading
virally and the evidence plain as day on
the video they should be able to be
identified so what we need to do is
actually contact the Bethel Ohio Police
Department the Chief of Police that all
this information is public okay so I'm
not daxing anybody the chief of police
is Steve Teague whose email which is
public is s as in Steve Teague te a gue
at Bethel - Ohio sorry
Bethel - o H gov be e th e L - o H gov
the phone number for the Bethel village
Police Department is five one three
seven three four two two five six we
should be respectful but we should be
asking number one that the attacker be
identified and arrested and number two
that these two officers actually be held
to account for doing absolutely nothing
as a crime was committed in front of
them they must be held accountable there
are multiple perpetrators here now more
generally what's been going on in Bethel
Ohio has been sick if you take a look at
news reports from the protests and
counter protests in Bethel the anti
black lives matter protestors have been
hurling racial slurs at protesters
intimidating them in one video which I
won't play today
a female counter protester approaches a
black protester
and repeatedly calls her the n-word /
WCPO
local news in another video a counter
protester approaches a protester who is
white and uses anti black racial slurs
anyway and asks why are you even here
you are white so horrible stuff going on
in Bethel we should contact the police
department we should demand both that
the perpetrator be identified and held
to account but also the police who did
absolutely nothing and if you've been
experiencing this type of thing if
you've seen this where you live let me
know on Twitter I'm
Twitter at de Pakman and remember that
you can get the David Pakman show audio
podcast for free every day on whatever
your favorite podcasting platform is be
that be it iTunes stitcher Google Play
Spotify wherever you want get the daily
audio podcast for the long-form version
of the show we'll take a quick break
much more is coming up today the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue ChiCom and use promo code David you
will get your first shipment completely
free just pay five dollars shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day at join pakman.com are rusty long
and heather collins thanks to both of
you horse membership the primary way
were funded we would not exist were it
not for great people like rusty and
heather getting memberships also a big
thank you to Marlene soul Gruber who is
today's longtime sustainer of the day
Marlene's been a member for almost 5
years unbelievable
grab a membership at joined pakman.com
one of the great member benefits just
one is the daily bonus show there's an
extra show every day where I'm joined by
producer Pat for more news and analysis
join pakman.com is the place to sign up
okay I have something truly special for
you today I'm gonna play a three-minute
clip of Mike Pence speaking now please
don't tune out don't turn this I know
that that's disgusting but there's a
reason for this
normally I don't play three-minute clips
on the show normally we cut them up I
play a little segment I analyze it so on
and so forth playing the full three
minutes here is critical to
understanding the anatomy of not
answering a question Mike Pence vice
president was interviewed on Fox and
Friends yesterday morning and Brian
Kilmeade asks a very straightforward
question the question Brian asked is is
it harder for someone who is black to
make it in the United States today in
2020 very straightforward question Mike
Pence talked for three minutes but said
absolutely nothing that could count as
an answer so let's just watch it's three
minutes sit through it I apologize but
pay close attention to what Mike Pence
says because you will notice that he
actually doesn't say anything about the
question that he was asked to for
someone who's black to make it in this
country whether they're man or woman do
you think it's harder for them to make
it in this country in 2020 well Brian I
love your question because I saw where a
Joe Biden last night actually tweeted
that everybody ought to have a fair shot
at the American dream and it's one of
the reasons why as the president
we're talking as the president spoke in
Dallas last week he's made it clear that
while we're going to take a step today
to provide new resources to law
enforcement to help them you know
embrace higher standards on
de-escalation and the use of force and
and and have an established in
information sharing I mean you know as I
said nobody hates bad cops more than
good cops and most of the men and women
who put on the uniform of law
enforcement every day are really the
best of us we know that so we're going
to take these steps today to help
improve policing to help to move that
process forward as a country in the wake
of these tragic events and the violence
that ensued but we're not going to stop
there Brian
I mean if Biden says everybody ought to
have a fair shot at the American dream
well we would say well well why don't
you support allowing african-american
families to choose where their kids go
to school I mean this president has
actually stood strong for school choice
we've doubled the educational choice
program here in our nation's capitol and
we really do believe that that you
shouldn't you shouldn't be denied the
ability to choose where your kids go to
school just because of your zip code or
because of your income we also as you
said under this president's policies we
had the lowest unemployment level ever
recorded for African Americans we worked
with senator Tim Scott to to enact
Opportunity Zones now there's more than
4,000 Opportunity Zones that have
attracted a hundred billion dollars of
investment into our cities we're going
to continue to drive forward on jobs and
opportunity I mean we understand the the
media narrative around this time and the
negativity around this time but as as I
sat down with African American leaders
in Pittsburgh in Maryland as the
president welcomed leaders here to the
it to the White House and in Dallas I
think I think millions of African
Americans saw the progress that we were
making over the last three years and
they know as we bring this economy back
in the wake of
of not just these tragic events and the
end the violence that ensued but in the
wake of course of this coronavirus
pandemic that its president Donald Trump
who has the prescription for more
prosperity more educational opportunity
and in really more access to the
American Dream than 50 years of Democrat
leadership under the likes of Joe Biden
has ever given them okay so to remind
you what the question was
because you might have forgotten while
Mike Pence was rambling the question was
is it harder for black people to make it
in the United States today it's really a
question that goes to systemic racism
not about individuals but about systems
and Mike Pence doesn't even come close
to even talking about it Mike Pence's
answer was to criticize Joe Biden to
talk about giving law enforcement more
resources to talk about good cops
dislike bad cops to remind us that most
cops are good he brought up this tired
school choice talking point which we'll
get to later pence mentions we had low
black unemployment and he worked with a
black guy named Tim Scott I'm gonna come
back to that the media is being very
negative
he said I've spoken to black people
Trump knows how to bring prosperity to
people and Democrats are bad so Mike
Pence said ten different things during
those three minutes none of which are
answers to the questions so now let's go
back briefly to black unemployment
unemployment is was really low before
the virus remember how during Barack
Obama's presidency Republicans insisted
there are more people than ever not
working in the United States and then
the day Donald Trump became president
the same Republicans were saying we have
more people than ever working in the
United States the explanation for that
talking point was or is the population
keeps growing so at most times it is
true that we have more people working
than ever before and more people not
working than ever before similarly with
this low black unemployment talking
point that Trump and pence love to use
when unemployment is low its GN
early low for all groups again unless
some group is particularly unaffected by
things going well overall there was
nothing special that Donald Trump did
for black Americans that would lower
their unemployment rate relative to
other groups unemployment was just low
for for everybody
until coronavirus hit so now we get to
the real question Brian Kilmeade after
which is there an interesting question
is it tougher to make it if you were
black in the United States
for me the clearest way to think about
this is would I want to switch to being
black or brown right now would I be
better off would I have been better off
growing up if I had been black or brown
and the answer is of course not of
course not because I know that if I were
black or brown I would be treated
differently and I would not be better
off today we all know it in fact I don't
even have to think about the
hypothetical of being black I can think
about something much more tangible I'm
an immigrant from Argentina I learned
English when I was five moved to the
United States
I have very white skin if I and my
parents moved to the US not as white
Hispanic folks but as black I'm sorry
brown Hispanic folks I think would be
the way to say it I would have been
treated differently from the moment we
got here my parents would have been
treated differently from the moment that
we got here and despite having made big
progress when it comes to race in the
United States and we have I don't deny
that I know that we would have been
worse off now by the way I don't often
hear people on the Left say this the
United States is definitely less racist
than many other countries I've been to a
lot of places in the world and lots of
them are more racist than the United
States often these are places that are
much more homogeneous and less diverse
than the United States the u.s. is not
as far as I'm concerned the most racist
country that's not actually at issue
here the point is we have the resources
to do way better and we still have major
problems with race and the answer to
Brian Kilmeade question to Mike Pence is
of course it's tougher to make it in the
United States in 2020 if you are black
or brown that still is the case and Mike
Pence managing to spit out three minutes
worth of words
while saying nothing at all about what
he was asked about the version of Donald
Trump that I call downer Trump showed up
yesterday in the Rose Garden to sign an
executive order about police departments
directing police departments to stop
using choke holds and Donald Trump did
look very very unwell and he said things
that made no sense whatsoever so this
again raised questions about whether
Donald Trump is suffering the side
effects of some illness side effects of
medication cognitive decline something
else that we can't seem to put a finger
on we discussed yesterday on the bonus
show extensively the question of police
using choke holds and the reality that
the priority should be rather than a
list of tactics that police Canon can't
use the focus should be on training
officers to de-escalate situations so
that choke holds aren't even in the
picture but we talked about that
yesterday right now I want to focus on
the absolute implosion of Donald Trump
during this Rose Garden statement here
is Donald Trump saying that we have
developed a vaccine for AIDS now that's
not true we have not developed a vaccine
for AIDS and Trump when he says it gets
that look on his face where he seems to
understand that he said something wrong
but he almost is lost and doesn't know
what he said it was like that time where
he did the oranges of the investigation
thing and he kind of tries to back it up
and mumbles a few things take a look at
this they have come up with things and
they've come up with many other cures
and therapeutics over the years these
are the people the best the smartest the
most brilliant anywhere and they've come
up with the AIDS vaccine they've come up
with or the AIDS and as you know there's
various things and now various companies
are involved but the therapeutic for
AIDS AIDS was a death sentence and now
people live a life with a pill it's an
incredible thing
the Ebola Veck so that same confusion
happened when Trump repeatedly said he
wanted to find out the oranges the suit
Triss fruit of an investigation he said
it twice and he had a look where he knew
he was saying something that didn't make
sense but he almost couldn't even parse
it in his own mind it didn't get any
better during this same event Donald
Trump seemed to lose his train of
thought this is another pattern we've
seen where he forgets what he's talking
about he will just look at someone and
say right you know what I'm talking
about don't you we've seen this before
this time he looks into the audience and
he says right Tim we're gonna pursue
things very strongly you can tell if
you're watching that Trump doesn't seem
lucid when you look at his face right
when this is happening take a look and I
gave a commitment to all of those
families today with Senator Tim Scott
terney General Bill Barr we are going to
pursue what we said we will be pursuing
it and we will be pursuing it strongly
Tim right okay wacky stuff at another
moment Donald Trump was talking about
putting down the protesters by using the
National Guard and of course putting
down is certainly not the most humane
language to use Trump bragging about how
strongly the protesters were handled and
your federal government is ready willing
and able to help as we did in
Minneapolis after it got out of control
for four days sent in representatives
commonly known as the National Guard and
it was all put down very quickly we're
willing to help with willing to help in
Seattle we're willing to help anywhere
you want so when there are protests
against police brutality and your
response is to brag about how much force
you directed to be used against the
protesters something is not quite
getting through then Donald Trump
absolutely bizarrely interjecting a
complete non sequitur about school
choice being the civil rights issue of
our time take a look at this we're
fighting for school
which really is the civil rights of all
time in this country frankly school
choice is the civil rights statement of
the year so understand that when
Republicans talk about school choice
what they really mean is defund public
schools week in public schools often
with voucher programs which go to
charter schools which then continues the
vicious cycle of worsening public
schools because you've just pulled money
from them this is a favorite of
Republicans say public education is bad
of course it's underfunded use that to
justify taking more money out of public
education which makes it worse so that
then they can again justify look at how
bad public education is we've got to do
more charter schools and private schools
it's a old trope from Republicans and
then lastly here another one of these
moments where Donald Trump lists
different races and ethnicities and
incorrectly claims that almost everybody
had a high-paying job before the corona
virus hit
that's for almost every group including
black Hispanic Asian women young people
old people young people without a high
school diploma every group everybody was
thrilled everybody had just about high
paying jobs our country was never in a
better position and we were planning on
massive growth it was happening it was
already there so one of the things we've
seen in terms of job creation before
coronavirus hit was that while the jobs
numbers were good and I have no problem
admitting that a lot of the jobs being
created were what we call BS jobs not
medium or high wage jobs but low wage
jobs or sometimes jobs that aren't even
really jobs there contractor positions
and this is a common deception that we
are hearing from the right so there it
is a combination of Donald Trump looking
and sounding confused making verifiably
false claims and the mood in the
audience a combination of quiet
confusion horror but also blind loyalty
the people that see this and at least
tell themselves that everything is
completely fine so we're gonna be
following up on this on our Instagram
page if you're not following the show on
Instagram please do at david pakman show
and in fact this is getting so bad that
it has gone on to Fox News Fox News
talking about the Trump health situation
a Republican group now targeting Trump
around health concerns so this is
important that it has broken past just
certain areas and even elements of the
right are now talking about Trump's
health and being put in a position to
have to defend it we'll get to that
after the interview today the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world's
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at join
pakman.com coupon code saves you 40%
vote soon 18 welcome back to the David
Pakman show it is great to welcome John
Perkins back to the program he's an
activist and also author of the classic
book Confessions of an economic hitman
more recently the author of touching the
Jaguar which is available now John great
to have you back it's wonderful to be
with you again David thank you I love
you to show you do great stuff so I
appreciate being on your show thank you
thank you well listen I wanted there's
so many things I want to ask you about
one is from your perspective if
coronavirus has served as a sort of way
to test the economic system that we have
which you know so much about and have
have critiqued in so many interesting
ways over the years what has coronavirus
exposed about the underlying reality of
our economic system well you know to
answer that I just a little story here
that a number of years ago
I took a group of people you know I take
people to the shamans of Latin America
on trips and we were with a lady shaman
high in the Andes of Ecuador Quechua
speaking shaman with a wonderful name of
Maria Juana Maria Juana yeah
young Bella and I was translating
someone asked hey Maria Juana how do we
save the earth and she laughed and she
said you know the earth isn't in danger
but we are and a bunch of other species
we take with us then she pointed up with
this huge sacred volcano that lives near
her house and that hovers over her house
our husbands our house called in by
border and she said a few years ago 20
years ago that that volcano was covered
with a massive ice cap it isn't anymore
mother earth is is twitching we're like
so many fleas if we get to be too much
of a nuisance she'll just move shake us
all off and she's twitching now she's
showing us the the glaciers are melting
and you know I thought I thought David
over the years every time there's been a
major hurricane or fires and in
Australia and California or whatever and
what these once in 100-year events that
happened every year or so now I
remembered what Maria Juana said but you
know that and and that they've been
sending us a message that this death
economy doesn't work we got to create a
new system but we've we've taken that as
a local thing so if I survive a
hurricane I expect outside the outside
world to come to help me bring water
food etc the corona virus has taught us
that there is no outside world this is
global everybody on the planet is being
impacted and we're seeing you know
people can see stars over over Shanghai
in Los Angeles these days it's having a
huge impact with all of our lives are
changing we don't like change human
beings don't really like change but
we've all been forced to change
radically and we're coming to understand
that maybe some of those changes are
further better that actually make life
more interesting more fun so when you
worked as a self-described economic
hitman you were able to essentially I
mean I don't think I'm speaking out of
turn by saying profiting from some of
the underlying fragility of the system
that we have which a lot of people may
not really see as fragile do you agree
that coronavirus has exposed that even
stable seeming economies are actually
far more fragile and in a matter of just
a couple of weeks can fall apart very
quickly
it's absolutely exposed that and it's
also exposed the tremendous inequalities
that our system is filled with you know
the racial discrimination the gender
discrimination all all this all these
inequalities are really coming to the
surface so I think the coronavirus is
showing us our shadow side and in fact
the way many governments have reacted to
it has shown us are set a shadow side
too and shown us that the old system
isn't working we
want to return to normal we want to
create a new new normal that's a we call
it life economy and so can you talk a
little bit about as specifically as you
want what those changes would be I mean
one of the fundamental realities of the
economy we have is that being proactive
is fundamentally not encouraged because
proactive just means you're spending
money on stuff you might not actually
need to spend money on essentially right
you're spending money now for something
that may happen but but it may not what
are the changes that would need to be
made in order to have what you call a
life economy what some might call a more
sort of human centered capitalism or
some other term that would be applied to
it
well yeah David so a great deal of the
book touching the Jaguar centers around
the idea that the truth that human
reality is molded by human perceptions I
learned that when a shaman saved my life
in 1969 deep in the Amazon but it's also
the basis of modern psychotherapy of
quantum physics of marketing of
advertising if corporate policy our
perceptions control our reality
this death economy what we many
economists are referring to the death
economy because it it's consuming in the
short term the resources upon which it
depends on the long term it's exhausting
and it's destroying the environment as
we know it and it's based on one
perception and that is that businesses
have the goal must have the goal of
maximizing short-term profits for a few
investors really regardless of the
social and environmental cost and that's
taken us down this very very dangerous
road so what we really need to change is
that perception we need to touch that
Jaguar and I'm touching that Jeff all
the time it's the Jaguar that that keeps
us locked in the fear that changes is
dangerous and you know we don't want we
don't want too much change but what we
need to do is change that goal that
perception of that in the goal needs to
be instead of maximizing short-term
profits to maximize long-term benefits
for humans and and the
in all of nature part of that I mean
that this critique so you know in the
business cycle it's about what was your
quarterly profit what did you do for the
year what was earnings per share the
political system is also based around
this right in the sense that if members
of Congress are up for re-election every
two years if the president's up for
reelection every four you're essentially
constantly campaigning and this also at
a systemic level encourages what can you
justify that you did in the last six
months rather than how did you improve
the country for the next twenty or
thirty years right and that's that's
exactly what needs to change so so let's
you know encourage businesses to invest
to pay investors to invest in things
that clean up pollution that regenerate
destroyed environments that recycle that
come up with new technologies you know
we've gone a long way with wind and
solar but in a way those are both in
their infancy let's move beyond that was
let's channel the air into forms of
energy this there's so much that we can
do and we've learned how to be creative
during this coronavirus you know for as
an example over 50 percent of your tax
dollars in mine if you're an American
citizen I go to the military in the
discretionary budget and and our
military is doing some crazy things like
building more aircraft carriers and
missiles and and and things that the
Russians and Chinese are not focusing on
at all they're focusing on cybernetics
and they're focusing on US technologies
imagine if some of that money that would
currently paying Raytheon and General
Dynamics to use to build these systems
that are basically obsolete instead we
put that money to encouraging these
companies and entrepreneurs and other
companies to mine all the plastic that's
floating around in the oceans and and
all the oil that's leaked around oils
get gas stations all over the world and
in the oil drilling sites and there's so
much more there's so many many things
like that that we can pay people to do
we're talking about a full employment
economy here we're talking about a life
economy what we're talking about instead
of making those widgets and stuff that
you mentioned earlier that people don't
really need and in a way we
probably don't even really want except
we're given the impression hey if you
don't wear this shirt nobody's gonna
want to date you impression this is
perception that's created our reality we
need to create another reality that what
we really want to invest in are the
things that will make life better for
all of us and for future generations
right I mean my framework as I you know
I don't necessarily need to label
everything but I think an ideology that
pretty well describes my views would be
social democracy which is that there are
areas where I'm fine with the market
directing resources as long as the
market is well regulated and it's a fair
market and the government as you say is
saying there are some things that are
bigger than profit so for example
cleaning up the oceans may not be
particularly profitable in the way that
we would measure it in the short term
but the long term value of it to humans
is such that that should be taken
outside of the market forces is that
more or less that the ideology are
applying it is David and and I think we
have to look at the definition of what
what's successful statistically the
measurement as you as you pointed out
GDP isn't is the standard measurement
tool and it's a lousy one and I just got
that when I was a an economic hitman
that that I thought that because I was
taught in business school that if you
invest a lot of money in infrastructure
and in poor countries that have
resources your corporations want you use
those resources as collateral that helps
everyone because you can show that when
you do that the GDP grows well they came
to see over time that that's really only
helping the very wealthy people because
GDP is very skewed toward the wealthy so
if you take for example the United
States with three individuals have as
much wealth as half the half the
population of our country if those three
individuals made ten percent in return
on their investment last year and half
the population lost three percent we're
still sure growth of GDP of something a
little under five percent so the
measuring-rods
we're using do not tell us anything
about true prosperity in a country they
tell us about the prosperity of the
wealthy the big businesses and those the
people who own those big businesses and
so we really need to change that whole
way of how we look at what's successful
and measure success much more in in the
long term and how it impacts everybody
not just the big owners the big
businesses what are some of the metrics
you would suggest including I recently
read the Charles Wieland's book naked
economics and there's things I like it
and things I disagree with but one of
the things he talks about is we should
at minimum if we want to evaluate how an
economy is doing we we can include GDP
we should look at unemployment we should
look at inequality we should look at
poverty we should look at trade balance
although individually none of these
metrics tells us everything we need to
know they can start to paint sort of a
picture what do you think of those what
would you add what what would you be
looking at well there's so many things
along those lines I mean we should we
should be measuring the value of
somebody doing housework at home that
woman man doing housework
taking care of the kids the value of
people making music you know a urine
embossed and there's a lot of amazing
musicians in all over New England that
I'm making a living doing it they got to
make a living doing something else and
then in the evenings they go off and
play their music these this is this is a
huge value it's same as writers our
artists there's so many things labor
should be should be considered much more
valuable than it's considered a labor of
all kinds our health care workers and on
and on and on there's so many measures
one of the most important ones is that
we don't include externality so when an
oil company drills for oil in a country
let's say Ecuador where I was a Peace
Corps volunteer and it's been lodged
part of Ecuador's environments been
destroyed by Texaco now Chevron that
they don't have to pay for that that's
not included in the price of oil that
they that they charge they just dump the
waste they don't have to pay for the
cleanups or all the people that suffered
but that's true throughout all the
businesses it's not just the oil
companies there's all these
externalities they should be included in
the cost and when you start including
them you see that that
other things have a great deal more
value is that the biggest failing of
markets if you had to pick what it is
that they'd really don't even though
efficient market hypothesis folks tell
us that markets do account for
externalities that they really don't and
that's where you need government to step
in yeah any any any accountant will tell
you that the externalities many of them
are not included at all you know that
the people that are used in sweatshops
overseas or now a lot of its by you know
the people that answer their telephone
calls in other countries their health is
not paid for it's not taken into account
if they get sick they get fired and yes
and that's a lousy that's a terrible
system so so yeah that certainly is a
starting point but I think the most
important thing that we all need to
understand is the basis of the system
the the assumption is based on this
perception that you must maximize
short-term profits regardless of the
social in the car an environmental cost
and this means that a CEO is is actually
given the mandate to do whatever it
takes to maximize profits and that may
mean destroying the environment
destroying the resources upon which his
company depends in the long run in order
to make short run profits it exploiting
labor corrupting politicians and and now
it means you know these companies have
learned how to corrupt politicians
legally because as we all know nobody
gets elected to a big public office in
the United States without huge amounts
of money that basically is generated by
corporations one way or another and and
these people are offered incredible
high-paying jobs as consultants
lobbyists whatever when they when they
leave politics so so we've got this
system where where CEOs are basically
forced by the investors by Wall Street
by their owners to do whatever it takes
to maximize short-term profits and
that's proven to be insanity it's taken
us down this course that's caused so
many problems when you come right down
to it David
the coronavirus the racial
discrimination climate change income
inequality species extinctions those are
all problems but they're not the disease
they're not the problem they're symptoms
of the disease and the disease is in
economic it's really a governmental
social economic system that we can call
the death economy that just plain isn't
working anymore it had worked it gave us
amazing science and medicine and art and
so many things but it's reached its
limits it's time is over it's time to
move into a new system of life economy
the book is touching the Jaguar now
available we've been speaking with the
book's author John Perkins John always
great having you on I so appreciate your
time thank you so much David and I would
just like to point out that the subtitle
of the book is transforming fear into
action to change your life in the world
and yes in the there's a whole process
that people can go through on a daily
basis or a weekly basis for about ten
minutes that guide each individual
whether you're a carpenter or a plumber
or radio show host or a writer like me
that'll take you down this course to
transform your life and they end in the
world the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
so this is very interesting I teased
this earlier in the show Donald Trump's
daughter-in-law
Lara Trump was interviewed on Fox News
this week and she was actually asked
about the health concerns surrounding
Donald Trump after his completely
outrageous behavior during the West
Point commencement speech that he gave
over the weekend now I want to be like
crystal clear what's important about
this is not so much what Lara Trump says
obviously Larry Trump says Trump's fine
right that's not surprising we wouldn't
expect her to say anything other than
that what matters here is that the story
actually made it on to Fox News back in
2016 in all of those bogus Hillary
Clinton has Parkinson's type stories
Hillary's unhealthy Hillary's dying
stuff even now stories about Joe Biden
and we see Tucker Carlson and Sean
Hannity sort of allude to Joe Biden's
cognitive state we have not seen any
mentions of Donald Trump's obviously odd
behavior that could be related to health
we already discussed on the Monday show
Trump struggling to drink a glass of
water and you know sort of having to use
his other his left hand to to help
himself drink water at West Point we saw
the video of Trump almost being helped
down a ramp by a military officer
looking incredibly ginger and unstable
and frail raised a whole new host of
questions about Trump's health so here
is Fox anchor Martha McCallum actually
asking Lera Trump about health concerns
take a look the hubbub over this well I
think it's sort of sad that nobody
focused on what the president actually
said at his address there at West Point
it was such a message of unity and
togetherness and strength of America and
how proud he was of all of those
graduates there it was yeah it was so
nice instead people Martha of course
focus on the way he walks down a ramp
this was a ramp that was you know had no
steps no handrail the president had on
leather shoes of course he's going to
take his time and go down and I got it
nobody wants to fall down in front of
cameras no I get it but just just to ask
you you know Street out is there
anything about the president's health
that the
in public doesn't no no absolutely not
it's just fodder for the critics out
there to attack us so of course it's not
surprising that Larry Trump says
everything's completely fine and there's
nothing to see here about Donald Trump's
health that's not really why I'm talking
about this the point is the fact that
this was even on Fox News is huge
because it means that the issue of
Trump's health is now on the radar of
some of these right-wing Trump
sycophants who primarily get their news
from Fox News and wouldn't ordinarily
hear about this story so understand that
were it not for segments like this there
is a huge portion of the country that
wouldn't even know anything about Donald
Trump's confused speech and limited
reading ability visible confusion the
often dilated pupils while sweating his
strange stance and all of these other
signs that have been topics of concern
around the country for years at this
point in time so I'm not really praising
Fox News and any kind of broader way but
it's a good thing that the story
actually made it on the air because this
is likely the first time that a ton of
Trumpets fox news watchers are even
hearing about the fact that there are
health questions surrounding Donald
Trump now also just kind of in the vein
of fact-checking
remember that initially Donald Trump
explained the reason that he walked down
the ramp so slowly and gingerly was that
the ramp was slippery Donald Trump
tweeted over the weekend quote the ramp
that I descended after my West Point
commencement speech was very long and
steep had no handrail and most
importantly was very slippery the last
thing I was going to do is fall for the
fake news to have fun with final ten
feet I ran down to level ground momentum
so that was quickly identified as bogus
because people just looked at weather
reports and video of the event it had
been completely dry and sunny all day so
the ramp was not slippery notice that
now there's a new explanation from lera
Trump which is that there was no
handrail and there were no steps and
that Trump was wearing
shoes the no steps thing is extra funny
because by definition ramps don't have
steps it's like well he would have gone
down the ramp faster if it had steps
well then it wouldn't be a ramp would it
it would be stairs so ultimately what do
we make of the ramp incident I don't
know here's a side by side video for our
television audience of Joe Biden and
Donald Trump both walking on ramps the
level of mobility is clearly very
different does this mean anything other
than Trump is getting older maybe not
the point is we don't know it could be a
sign of a stroke it could be a sign of
really anything we just don't know and
importantly none of this is anything to
make fun of Donald Trump is 74 years old
he's obese it's not shocking that he
would have some mobility issues but the
point is the constant dishonesty and
attacking others never answering
questions straight up and increasingly
deceptive feeling statements and actions
when it comes to his health which we'll
talk about later including the
completely bogus thing from 2019
remember where he was rushed to Walter
Reed Medical Center and we were told you
know what he just had a few free hours
he decided to get a jump on that 20/20
physical it wasn't believable and now
even some Republican groups are making
this a focus let's talk about that next
okay so in the last 24 hours
the health questions about Donald Trump
have appeared not just on Fox News as we
already talked about but the health
questions around Trump has also become a
focus of a new ad from the Republican
pack Republican political action
committee called the Lincoln project now
we've talked about the Lincoln project a
little bit before it's a PAC run by some
prominent
Republicans this includes George Conway
who by the way is the husband of Trump
advisor Kellyanne Conway a Steve Schmidt
is part of the Lincoln project former
McCain campaign manager Rick Wilson and
other prominent Republicans they are a
Republican pack that realizes Trump is a
danger and must be removed their ads
have been going after Trump harder and
harder and yesterday they released an ad
that goes after Donald Trump on the
topic of his
again raising questions about Trump's
behavior over the weekend at West Point
linking Trump's behavior to the
last-minute visit to Walter Reed Medical
Center in 2019 so let's look at the ad
let's listen to the ad now some of these
elements are visual like for example
you'll hear voice over and they are
showing Donald Trump acting bizarrely so
I do recommend watching this online but
you'll get a sense of the story that's
being told from the narration let's take
a look
something's wrong with Donald Trump he's
shaky weak trouble speaking trouble
walking so why are we talking about this
and why isn't the press covering Trump
secretive midnight run to Walter Reed
Medical Center why do so many reporters
who cover the White House and pretend
they can't see Trump's decline the most
powerful office in the world needs more
than a week
unfit shaky president Trump doesn't have
the strength to lead nor the character
to admit it we're not doctors but we're
not blind it's time we talk about this
Trump is not well so this is really
quite well done even the details doubt
that down to the details it's very good
at one point when the voice-over says we
are not doctors what you see in the ad
is Trump's old dr. Harold Bornstein on
screen that's the guy that Donald Trump
allegedly coerced into writing that
bogus letter about how healthy Donald
Trump is so we are now seeing this I
guess we would call it a sort of hashtag
movement Trump is not well is the name
of it and it's going much more
mainstream than it ever has it's
happening thanks to right-wing media
it's happening thanks to a Republican
political action committee and to go
back to the analysis this is not about
Republicans are now going to be widely
concerned about Donald Trump's health
that's not going to happen the
importance of this is that there are
large swaths of the American population
that don't even know that there's been a
conversation about Trump's health
happening for three years there
large portions of the electorate that
have no idea that dozens of medical
experts both from the Naropa neurology
field and mental health fields have been
expressing concern about Donald Trump's
health for years because they watch Fox
News and they only follow Republicans on
social media they don't know about
Trump's verbal glitches his wandering
off that time when he came off of Air
Force One his limo was right in front of
him he wandered off had to be brought
back by Secret Service losing his train
of thought sweating with the dilated
pupils while speaking upper Trump versus
downer Trump they don't know about it so
even hearing about this as a thing on
Fox News and through a Republican pack
is introducing it into their awareness
now 99% of them won't care but remember
that in 2016 the election came down to
75,000 votes in three states we will
mostly win if we get the turnout but
we'll take any help we can get and if
it's a Republican pack and Fox News
asking even some questions about Donald
Trump's health you might convince a few
people and we will take it now there are
reports about this ad being
controversial for example this there's
an article this morning in the week
which is called new Lincoln project ad
controversial II questions Trump's
health it's not really controversial if
you've been following this for years and
there's a debate happening in this
article and elsewhere asking whether
Trump's health is fair game now one
argument is listen Trump mocked a
disabled reporter he calls Joe Biden's
sleepy Joe and says Joe Biden doesn't
even know what he's saying he is
regularly implying Joe Biden is
cognitively impaired so that makes
Trump's health fair game
I disagree with that assessment the
reason Trump's health is fair game is
because he's the president and we have
reason to believe that he's lying about
his health
his medical report lied about his height
and weight combination he allegedly
coerced a doctor to write a letter
saying Trump would be the healthiest
president in history it's an empirical
claim that no doctor could actually make
so
I understand the concern from disability
rights groups worried that this is
bordering on making fun of health issues
that is not what this is about this is
about understanding the critical nature
of being president and when you have a
president that number one seems unwell
and number two is dishonest about
everything including his height and
weight
we are absolutely right to be concerned
that's really what this is fundamentally
about we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine to david p to
sort of put a coda on our discussion of
donald trump's health here is a nurse
who called in she's delightful by the
way who says she believes stroke may be
the explanation for trump's trouble
drinking water from favoring one side
when walking down that ramp at Westpoint
let's take a listen to what she had to
say I gave it you are absolutely the
best thank you
just watched your commentary about yes
and I believe he's had a stroke I'm a
nurse practitioner I seen a lot of that
anyway thank you thank you yes a bunch
of nurses actually wrote to me and they
said that the one-sided thing that
seemed to be going on with Trump is to
them indicative of a stroke I am NOT
making that claim myself merely telling
you what some nurses have reported to me
we have a great bonus show for you today
we are going to talk about the Trump
administration absolutely panicking
about the upcoming release of John
Bolton's White House memoir Boulton of
course one of trumps former national
security advisors and the Justice
Department is now actually trying to
take legal action to block the
publication of the book they are scared
they are scared Boy Scouts of America
not typically the most left-wing
organization you can imagine
particularly when it comes to gay rights
is backing black lives matter we're
going to talk about what they're doing
and how they're doing it and lastly
Albuquerque is going to put in place a
system where when a 911 call comes in
depending on what the call is about
instead of
dispatching armed police social workers
will be dispatched this is one of the
primary recommendations I had in my
multiple segments about how to fix
police very interesting and we will talk
about all of those stories and talk
about yesterday's chess tournament which
had over 700 players participate on the
bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue chicom and use the promo code david
i've put a link right underneath this
video